[Music]
in wrong number news Tommy submitted I
haven't seen you since now I'm saying a
text to the wrong number ends up raising
money for a child with cancer how this
miracle happen who has cancer his four
year old boy oh god dude
poor guy yeah he has pre BC cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemia that sounds crazy
it sounds wild it's like an autoimmune
disease what sounds like probably
something like that I don't know the
difference but it sounds serious
I always feel bad when little kids get
these diseases cuz they're so innocent I
just get [ __ ] with the minute they're
born yeah alright so this all started
with this tweet here it says SID Sidney
Sidney accidentally sent pics of her
dress to the wrong number and this was
their response so these are the photos
of the dress and the response says I
believe this message was intended for
someone else my wife isn't home so I
couldn't get her opinion but the kids
and I think you look stunning in your
dress you should definitely go with that
all five kids oh okay yeah that's a lot
of kids
that's an awesome picture that makes me
want to have five kids
well slow your slow it down I want a lot
of kids too man yep I want to wake up in
the morning I'm like can we get rid of
this one please no kidding I hear you
better I hear you don't ya I'll have
your back when you want five kids I'll
have your back when you want to get rid
of your wife go home we have two homey
got you true homey voltage before so
where is it where's the backup TIFF just
focus on this story you trying to tell
you can start look you hear the crickets
around you geo where's the words back up
yes my kids or wants to get rid of the
one tip why would you do that
can swim while jobs well played Minh
sorry
alright so Tony here he has six kids but
only five of them were in the photo
because his four year old son like we
mentioned he has cancer that's the cool
thing about having a lot of kids
[Music]
we did it we stopped them we averted the
disaster it's like we went back in time
we did it we this is how it feels when
we do it it's like we're ready yes
though you need to finish that sentence
because that's like holiness knees over
you say well if you have a lot of kids
and one disappears
you still got five why would you do
would you put him in that situation I
was just so cold on okay this is true so
it's my mom um you know grew up back in
the day
yup Great Depression times she says this
is this is why people had a lot of kids
back in a day that's true back in the
day that's very that's very true like
Asians like old Abe Lincoln had a lot of
kids and you smiled and Beckett you just
expect some to that she was it just
happens see that a well of knowledge man
you're both standing on a hangman's
stand wall nods right there yeah oh boy
you guys thought you defuse the right
water right well guess what I put that
[ __ ] right back together you're going
to help a little bit of putty in some
electrical tape very cool
I'm just following orders looking
forward to the channels next brand deals
good I'm just trying to be optimistic
here guys what trying to be optimistic
you need to be a counselor
alright so Tony says Society puts a lot
of pressure on these young women to have
a certain look and a certain body build
we try to teach our children to be
themselves and not worry about what
other what others think even with that
my young daughters already expressed a
desire to fit in and I figured this
young lady might need that reassurance
my wife wasn't home so I couldn't get
her opinion and I assumed that the
children thumb thumbs up in her would
accomplish that substantially better
than some overweight middle-aged Pollock
guy so that's why put himself down the
process I know why you gotta beat
yourself up dude yeah well he's like
he's like yeah girls got to respect
themselves and not really worry about
how they looked like overweight
middle-aged white bald guy what if he's
just saying facts though well that's
like saying facts if a girl's bad that's
fact some hater a dude that's yeah he's
drinking his own hater exactly uh so
anyway like I mentioned the four year
old wasn't in the photo
this is CAI's alert he is beautiful
so cute hair that's a cool name he has
cancer
mm-hmm his cool hair yeah his hair is
told yeah a super cool be like one of
those Nickelodeon kids that hair you
know it's gonna be a miracle he's gonna
survive yeah his other kids you I
watched a lot of movies guys and they
all turn out pretty damn well so they
have six kids total six total yeah so
then because of this going viral on
Twitter a lot of people's like they
found the family's Facebook page and the
families go fund me page for Kaiser and
so many people have donated the base
surpassed their goal like how did they
find out that a kid has cancer
yeah well yeah like they Twitter users
they somehow figured out who the family
oh so this went viral because he
complimented her dress yeah that was got
it and then because of that going viral
be found he found the kid has cancer
they wanted 10,000 but they got if you
know Dan that kid is [ __ ] cute as [ __ ]
he looks like though he looks like the
kid on stranger things
that's awesome and he got those [ __ ]
Michelle tanner thumbs up dude
can't say no to that you got it dude do
you think if the if the kid was ugly
they will get that much money you think
people judge kids like that yes I think
people are cold realistically no they
would not have given on this morning I
feel yeah I think the uglier they are
the more money they get I think if that
kid was like 17 Ugly Duckling sage
you're probably right yeah yeah all
dollars all cute even with their ugly
they're cute cuz it's like a pug you
know and you can't really judge a little
kid
they haven't had enough life excuse but
hey that's kind of like how how cats and
dogs have slowly evolved so that we take
more and more care of them
I think kids looks there's a reason why
they're they look like thank you sir
yes we want to take care of that [ __ ]
yeah if your dog was like 11 years old
right and then you have an operation
that could save them for another year
would you do it or would you just let it
pass if my dog was what 11 years old and
then there's an operation I could save
him for another year would you do it or
like we were actually in that exact same
situation but the operation also had a
50-50 chance of just because once when
they're that old the operation itself if
operated on a two-year-old thought they
would recover but because the dogs are
that well it's just gonna take them a
year to recover anyways we actually said
no just don't fall in love isn't that it
was also like there's just what I said
just don't fall in love with things you
don't have to deal with that [ __ ]
yeah way to go Joe no yeah I love and
lost so that's my rose again right my
dude no
no don't break my I have three or you
guys too but I have three Jessica Maddie
and Sophie and then after that I don't
know what the [ __ ] what about us
no I said I told you I added you guys
you guys have actually three yeah we
came after the dogs it makes sense like
his family family just boots is like
inter fan I would choose you guys before
my dogs
well that's because you're packing down
hey you know what you know what
realistically here's it it you're
hanging off a [ __ ] cliff I would try
your fingers off
[Laughter]
Mireille David if you were sitting on
the couch was hanging the edge of cliff
you just stay on the couch yes don't
[ __ ] lie to yourself so your scar and
she's Mufasa that's interesting I just
watch that again that sort of depending
if you really look at it
but thank you because scar was cool as
[ __ ] nobody likes scar Jeremy Irons dude
that's Jeremy Irons you know there he
goes Jeremy Irons legend hey did you
know ok did you know that older Simba
and this is relevant to the story by the
way older Simba is Matthew Broderick
really he's older similar King said why
it means Beth you've brought it would
look like no I was blown away by that
recently I was like wow so he goes from
gin Jonathan Taylor Thomas to Matthew
Broderick who's more of a man Jonathan
Taylor Thomas he's hanging out at some
of my party couple years ago did he did
he do anything after to a time he
doesn't need to he's richer than you'll
ever be in your life yeah but sometimes
it's not about the money that's like
what Frankie Muniz says I saw I see
people clowning on Frankie Muniz all
time like hey I haven't seen you since
like Big Daddy to you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he's like I have thirty
million dollars you suck it son of a
[ __ ] on Twitter it's great race car
driver and the drummer's gate is where
the [ __ ] he wants he's like I have
$100,000,000 kind of crazy like how
people are like you're not relevant
anymore right I could literally pay you
to suck my dick
even if you hate yeah like five hundred
thousand dollars suck my dick for three
seconds that's right
three only three good thank you mrs.
dick for three seconds who wouldn't do
it I'll ask him for a raise I'll be like
how about sixty Seconds does it count
does it add up like everything's [ __ ]
that I would cut the money down that's
what it is that's when it truly gets
dark cuz my buddy we were doing that
thing where it's like how much would it
be to suck a dick or whatever and my
buddy was like man I don't know five
hundred and we're like no not anymore I
got money dude this will start this will
start it off in like five bucks no not
anymore I mean yeah that's true but
these days I got money see life is good
life is good so life is good my price
gets higher 50k
maybe egos $5 $5 I'm like that's true
baby well we'll see we'll see how I'm
feeling if I'm like you know what if
you're the mood yeah good you know what
yeah that's the gauges on temperature
yeah I got an idea right now you know I
wanna I want to invest into Bitcoin
Bitcoin is kind of low that's true let
me [ __ ] suck that dick if you suck
that dick now yeah
later on you're not gonna have to suck
anything I'm trying to open up a [ __ ]
drink shop right now
but if I'm just me capital yeah I have
no ideas I'm like get that dick out of
my face
[Laughter]
[Music]